what else is the media prioritizing
right now well over at the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC
there's this guy we've played some
videos of him before it's hard to
believe he's a real person he appears to
be a villain from Gotham City Batman is
looking for this guy he's hanging out
with Two-Face and The Riddler and the
Penguin and give me one more Bane give
me one more Joker give me one more
poison ivy thank you his name is Anand
garage
something like that and uh he is very
upset that billionaires exist and I
wonder if he had the power as a Gotham
villain what he would do to billionaires
because guys like Elon Musk are
defending Free Speech appears to be a
game to him but letting Donald Trump
back in the room Kanye was posting uh
again yesterday as well what does it all
add up to you know first of all I think
something we often forget As Americans
is that billionaires exist as a class of
people who have that much money at our
Collective pleasure right it is a policy
choice to allow some people to
accumulate that much money hundreds of
billions of dollars in the case of
people in the United States before
everybody has the chance to live with
dignity he brings back Donald Trump
who's who's kind of unleashed the the
the the the white nationalist demons in
this country on that platform and off in
ways that are obviously have caused us
to come to the brink of losing our
democracy Elon Musk Big Ideas let's
bring him back he's gutted the company
photos of him from the company at a
so-called code meeting showed that
there's basically like no women left
working around him it's just a big
sausage fest in there working you know
in the team that he has remaining around
him their existence as as billionaires
is sort of antithetical to our
flourishing as a democracy
first off I feel like I have to
apologize to the Riddler and to the
Joker and Poison Ivy and Bane and some
of these other people these were
criminal masterminds these were people
with two-faced you may not like
everything that they're doing they all
had problems a lot of them going back to
their childhood but they they had some
insight into the world you know and it
was misguided and it often led to murder
and Mayhem staying in Arkham Asylum all
that stuff
um Arkham Asylum that's a good reference
you got that one right you definitely
didn't go you got it you got it wow all
right
um anyway they I should not compare them
to that completely crazy person on MSNBC
let's just go through some of that first
of all billionaires exist at our at our
pleasure you know billionaires I know
one or two billionaires
um
I don't know they're working and they're
creating things you don't just become a
billionaire by doing nothing you create
Industries you create incredible
products you create things like Tesla or
like PayPal or you create railroads back
in the day like you do these things
which then create hundreds of thousands
and often millions of jobs and you allow
all sorts of people to have some
Independence over their life so the idea
that you just want to take out that
those are the real problem if you right
now if that guy and on the evil Gotham
villain I don't want to give an evil
Gotham Bill and an idea but if he took
out the top 10 billionaires in America
if you just took them out and took all
of their money and then just gave all of
their money to America first off it
would do nothing on the debt but putting
that aside like if you just spread that
money out in a year from now there would
still be homelessness there would still
be all the problems and people would be
pissing all this money away and you have
to work to earn something we can discuss
whether there are tricks and games that
they play and all of those things on the
margins fine but the problem is not the
billionaires it's the government in the
first place that's one thing he said
then Trump unleashed the white
nationalist demons which I'm pretty sure
he's the evil Gotham guy here with the
white nationalist demons that does seem
like an evil character uh and then of
course we were on the brink of losing
democracy again they had no plans one
guy had the Lego set which turned out it
didn't even he didn't even bring it or
something uh and then he's going on
about this picture so Elon Musk posted a
picture it's like 1am in the Twitter
office a couple days ago and he's got
some bunch of programmers around him and
this picture went viral because it
appeared I don't know there were maybe
30 people around him and it appeared
that there were no women it turns out
there were at least four women that you
just have to kind of find them and it's
San Francisco so everyone's kind of a he
she man woman or whatever so you got to
kind of look around somebody's shoulder
and then you spot a chick or whatever
but either way Elon didn't you think
Elon went in there like dude guys I'm
gonna fire all the chicks